yes so next image please and we're gonna
sing this little mantra here so one of
the methods in access Sanskrit that is
Sanskrit baba nam kevalam you kate's
along he cave on a table ah yeah baba
nam kevalam baba baba nam kevalam yep we
leave a feeling of limitless so the idea
here is that we're going to focus on the
source of love inside ourselves so you
only takes a moment thought to observe
that you know all the love we've ever
experienced
comes from inside of ourselves so I want
to be in that place mm-hmm
so the idea is that you know there is
this part of ourselves that generates
this feeling and we're connecting to
that and that it doesn't have any limit
we're not going to put any boundary on
that so we're connecting to this source
of limitless love within ourselves all
right I'm going to sing the mantra for a
minute and we're going to guide you into
a very short super short meditation on
baba nam kevalam and this mantra right
so just close your eyes and sit straight
and if you're watching this which I hope
you are
yes it's right make yourself comfortable
feet flat on the floor maybe or you
might have a little meditation room of
your own if you're very lucky yeah now
close your eyes
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
just keep your eyes closed
and remember to sit straight
and breathe through your nose if you can
comfortably and keep your hands in your
lap
let the mantra baba nam kevalam with the
music continue in your mind as though
you are hearing it play back to you by
the voice of your memory you're just
observing you're listening and it's
playing on automatically
and if your mind wanders don't worry
that's perfectly natural but when you
notice that just bring your attention
back to the mantra and the music
and begin to feel that this mantra is
coming from a place deep within you as
though your inner self were singing to
you
and drawing your attention to this place
within you where the love comes from
so you're connecting to the source of
this feeling of love within yourself
and as you come deeper into it you
realize that it has no boundary
there are no limits
to the potential
of the love within you
to flip the mantra and the music
continue in your mind and it's drawing
your attention inward to this source of
limitless love
we just focus on that in silence for a
moment
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
just take a deep breath
did you breathe out you can relax
and you can open your eyes
so you can practice that at home every
day twice a day I'll give you a link
later where people can actually find a
download of a guided meditation like
that's free and that link will be in the
bio that yeah